das gibt es noch der bäckermeister schon
um mitternacht in seiner backstube mit
acht leuten machte 400 brote am tag
kneten
das ist wichtig für ein gutes deutsches
brot meinte friedbert england die
rezepte für die rocken misch und körner
brote kommen aus der familie
es gibt genug zeit zwei stunden darf das
programm
in der großbäckerei harry zählt dagegen
tempo kein einziger knetet hier noch per
hand 2000 brote pro stunde
und das an nur einer produktionslinie
es ist schön zu gewinnen
gute form
matthias müller hat noch in einem
handwerksbetrieb gelernt jetzt leitet er
die massenproduktion
für mich ist das realität weil das
herstellen von brot ist nach wie vor
braucht man handwerkliches geschick
dafür man muss auch großtechnische
anlagen bedienen können ohne frage
der durchsatz ist wesentlich höher als
in einem handwerksbetrieb aber die
qualität ist vergleichbar
der verkaufsschlager das kastenbrot
40.000 am tag backen sie allein am
standort berlin
so kostet das im supermarkt nicht einmal
zwei euro
der industrie ofen meter lang
die spezialität im familienbetrieb das
elztäler bauern groß es kommt nach 90
minuten aus dem ofen
alles handgemacht nur so können sie mit
großbäcker konkurrieren ihr feind sind
die lebensmittel discounter die backen
oft mit automaten eine maschine die
10.000 brötchen in der stunde macht mit
einem hilfsarbeiter immer günstiger 22
szenen oder einen gesellen hilfsarbeiten
fünf uhr morgens der chef liefert das
brot in seine fünf filialen noch selber
aus seine sauerteigbrot kosten im
schnitt zwischen drei und vier euro
das geschäft lebt von stammkunden
denn diesen bereit für qualität noch
richtig geld auszugeben
gewisse unterschied gibt's halt doch
zuruf gebackener logo klar was
handgemachtes natürlich selber
handwerker foto h mit der hand gemacht
ist immer gut
aus der waschstraße brote im
sekundentakt für matthias müller ist da
kontrolle das wichtigste überhaupt ein
metallschild rein ins fertige kosten
brot und
theoretisch schrauben drin sein von
unseren anlagenteilen es kann vom
rohstoff selber eine vereinigung drin
sein und das wird hier am metalldetektor
detektiert und ausgeschlossen
viel aufwand doch großbäckereien kämpfen
schon gegen genug vorwürfe da soll es
gar teig rohlinge aus china geben alles
quatsch sagt er
bei harry zumindest sei alles frisch und
frei von chemie
das macht einen schon eine gewisse art
und weise würden aber das nützt ja auch
nicht man muss eine zustellung beziehen
und darüber reden wir stellen unsere
backwaren ausschließlich in deutschland
her und für standorte sind in
nord- und mitteldeutschland verteilt und
dort liefern unsere bäcker ehrliche
arbeit ab und
dieses brot zu backen im odenwald hat
sich der familienbetrieb etwas einfallen
lassen um schritt zu halten mit den
großen für pendler gibt es einen bug
drive-in direkt an der bundesstraße
kurz nach sieben und viele holen sich
vor der arbeit noch schnell ein brötchen
ab 400 kunden am tag haben sie so
zusätzlich friedbert england ist seit
sieben stunden auf den beinen endlich
pause
jeder hat eine chance auf qualität sitzt
geschnitten und abgepackt noch am selben
tag geht das größten brot raus in über
9.000 geschäfte eben ein mächtiger
konkurrent zum kleinen bäcker um die
ecke